hey guys welcome to the room report i'm
dave rubin classing up the joint wearing
a jacket this week I've got Louis
Heitzman with me Jack Moore with me and
here we go are you drinking alcohol like
old-school alcohol that was mixed maybe
in a distillery or a winery or something
like that that is old school get new
school people it's now in powdered form
the alcohol tobacco tax and trade Bureau
has approved alcohol which is a powdered
alcoholic drink mix for sale and
distribution uh and basically it's
exactly what it sounds like it's
basically kool-aid that you just add
some water to and you can get smashed I
believe we have an image of some of the
packaging of Christian get a pot
cosmopolitan a mojito a powder Rita
which apparently tastes just like a
margarita and a lemon drop amongst a
couple others and there's been some
confusion on the internet whether this
was approved or was an approved which
seems like it's up to a bit of debate
the labels I guess haven't been approved
yet uh but uh would you drink powdered
alcohol is this the future is everything
gonna be in powdered form I feel very
conflicted because I don't drink bye
love novelty items so I feel like I kind
of want to have the powdered alcohol
just because it's ridiculous and like
you know it's a thing to do right would
you snort the powdered alcohol if you
don't drink as a non-drinker yeah no I
think that's a good loophole snorted or
like making a face mask out of it just
rub it into your skin yeah with a little
paste whatever it takes whatever i'm
gonna drink it not gonna drink it I just
think yak anything that makes making
jungle juice for college parties easier
is going to succeed so I can't imagine I
i feel like the prank potential of
powdered alcohol is really high you know
just to like your friends away and like
it's finally a fun surprise to leave in
someone's drink you know not a dangerous
one so you know you leave a little
powder rita in there and they get a nice
little surprise as they're having brunch
later than I you know I could see
college kids across america it's the new
the new trend on campus yes remember a
couple was it like a year ago there was
going to be beer that was just a vapor
and you could just get wasted like that
people always fight this
but you really can't fight progress can
you one day if people want to have a
little packet of powdered booze they're
gonna have it right now everything will
be okay yeah also like idea of
sprinkling alcohol on your food I was a
flavor enhancer or just to get drunk on
fries whatever it takes a margarita
french fries yet why not and get drunk
at the same time it's a feature not a
parable seemed like the future actually
yeah you've solved it um do you think
that they're gonna have you know
alternate companies they're gonna start
cutting it with stuff you know cuz
there's there is a drug element to this
you know you mean where you're gonna get
the pure stuff and then it's going to be
cut with some some drano or something
right gasoline gasoline whatever it is
yeah yeah it's just I I mean we really
have the equivalent I'm sure these
things just tastes like bad like wine
mixer is basically like the things the
things they sell in like pouches at you
know CBS was that all the wine cooler
brand like from the eighties those two
guys those two old guys bartels in jails
in jail like it would taste a lot
exactly so it's just it's that's my one
problem with is like do you need another
step towards alcohol like has anybody
ever been like man I love drinking but
if only there was another preparatory
step between me and getting drunk right
I don't think that you stop and you it's
actually better because you to think
about it you know like you're gonna have
a drink do I really want to open this
powder packet and mix it with water
right wait on that time couldn't it also
be the reverse of that like where people
want to get drunk easily let's say
you're at a baseball game and you don't
want to pay 12 bucks for a beer and you
can be like oh I got a bottle of water
well actually about a water probably
close a but you bring your own water and
then you know any insight on its crystal
light so financially it makes sense sure
if you were did once but I've just never
had like kool-aid and thought to myself
like man I wanna have koolaid more like
I want this to expand into other areas
of my life and so I don't the idea of
making alcoholic kool-aid doesn't
exactly have you told me like hey I made
a bunch of alcoholic kool-aid would you
like some I would definitely say nothing
you would not try that so is this really
though this seems to me that this is
really about kids drinking cuz that's
where that you know like they can of
course they're gonna market it to adults
but the people that are really going to
be some
toggling packets it to parties and
family event it's gonna be kids so there
is some risk I wanted package like Pixy
Stix we can have a handful and I'll open
my debt fund it's even better oh that
was your thinking outside the box yeah
now I want to use it as alcoholic fun
dip that actually is the best that
sounds great give us a white sugar
sticks and yeah I mean should be we be
concerned though about the kids the kids
we should always think it's always
someone has to be concerned about the
kids you know what's your name from the
simpsons Lovejoy's wife is all worried
about the kids it does seem uh like this
will be a very shop lifted item like
it's much easier to go into a store and
grab a little pouch of something it's
that will fit in anybody's pocket than
to like grab a bunch of bottles imagine
kids like pockets full of powder just
like grabbing and purple flower and
walking around just like leaving a trail
of alcohol behind them yeah it just has
so much so many occasion alcohol not
good sounds like a department of like
pals and alcohol which already is like
oh no so all right well maybe the
palcohol people have some marketing
issues to work on they still gotta get
the labels approved and everything so we
will see what happens and when it
becomes legal we will drink it here and
do official taste test alright let's
talk about prop 8 we can't do one week
without something gay and this one I
think is actually kind of interesting
sir charles cooper who is one of the
lawyers that was for prop 8 meaning he
was against marriage equality and fought
it at the Supreme Court well you're not
going to believe this he has
flip-flopped and yeah he's now for gay
marriage why well his step daughter
lesbian wants to get married incredible
how this works out we've got a quote
from general Cooper my views evolved on
issues of this kind the same way as
other peoples do and how I view this
down the road may not be the way I view
it now or how I viewed it 10 years ago
that's attorney Charles Cooper right so
basically that seems good to me he's
trying to get on the right side of
history except the Supreme Court case
wasn't that long ago and is it a little
disingenuous like now it affected you
personally so you're gonna get on the
right side like this kind of in a
we're wait i'm happy that happened but
it kind of seems like a dick move bakit
we canceled judge him right yeah yeah we
can totally judge them yeah no work
through this are you okay I'm fine with
it i mean good for him but like the firm
? yeah like good for you that you
personally affected you and now you're
deciding that you have to not be an
[ __ ] yeah can you guys at BuzzFeed do
some sort of one of those what do you
call them the freaking tests the you
know is it the quiz is that can you do
one of the quizzes on like how you
evolved on gay marriage with all your
crazy can you make that go did I right
now please after the show make up really
I mean I look it's good he did it but
like it's literally about what is it
about a year later something maybe it so
it's less than a year later it's like
nine months later and it seems like well
it affected you personally so now you're
gonna come on board like it it blows my
mind that there are still people in this
country who don't see that this war has
been lost by them like bigots have lost
this war it's just going to happen it's
not there's no going back now and to its
it's the equivalent of being a
segregationist in 1982 like it's you it
the wars done right and so the fact
what's more shocking me is that there
are there are so many people who haven't
evolved their stance on gay so should we
graciously accept this guy should be
like yeah sure you fought you fought
against us less than a year ago in the
Supreme Court but you found out you have
a lesbian stepdaughter welcome i mean i
think we're so excited thinking well we
are accepting but i also think it's a
great feather in the cap of the cause
that if even this guy i mean this is
this is darth vader like hanging out
with the Ewoks like it's it's impossible
to be touched by this issue personally
and not come to the right conclusion if
Dick Cheney who I'm pretty sure is an
evil robot sent from the future can be
for gay marriage because his daughter is
then really it's the least you can ask
him for somebody it's actually the least
you can add so is this just proof that
the number one thing the gay people can
do is come out because look it happened
with Dick Cheney when his daughter
I'm out he came around this guy's
daughter came out we had that was it Rob
Porter i think senator his son came out
so so it's basically like if you come
out you can pretty much affect the the
convictions propagation am the positive
way of thinking about it yeah instead of
being like sri be gracious which know we
will yes we should be gracious but
should we just accept that should the
game you just accept all these people no
matter what they've done in their past
should the second you change should you
be uh exonerated a boy I don't think she
liked marching in the pride parade but
we can like we can hate him what we can
this except that he evolved on the issue
without making him like a you know a gay
icon yeah I he wants to be a gay icon
but I think we should maybe not make him
one have to morph into an old lady
probably should wear away yeah but I
think no no um do you think it matters
even if he's not doing this necessarily
because of his daughter but just for
selling a book cuz I think that's also a
part of it like how do you sell your
book while I was the prop 8 lawyer
before it against gay marriage and now
I'm for it let's sell a book you know
like there's some element but should we
even take that and did I think I I think
whatever gets people on the right side
of this issue is a good thing and I
don't think that makes them great people
because I don't think this issue makes
being for gay marriage and saying that
people who love each other should be
able to get married doesn't make you a
good person that's just what as people
we should expect of each other you don't
want extra credit yeah well I mean I
would love some extra credit I was
giving them extra credit this whole time
will you get a totally for being a kia
and Ally for being an ally you know I I
do what I can yep uh does anyone involve
the other way that that's what this is
making me think is there anyone that's
pro-gay marriage that suddenly have we
heard that at all as may be that way
troopers went to Berkeley which is a
very liberal school but the largest
group on campus are actually they called
Republicans because people come for like
moderate and they're so freaked out by
the liberalism that they like backtrack
and become these really conservative
like [ __ ] so I feel like that could
happen like some I get so scared about
like it marriage equality like I'm gonna
just a minute like double down and
become like super anti after thinking
this was okay yeah
a little bit of like the chick-fil-a
theory like the more you fought the more
the gays for chick-fil-a the more
chicken they sold like a little bit of
that or the more that they fought duck
dynasty suddenly the ratings were huge
now I guess they're not okay Paula Paula
Deen still people rally behind Paula
Deen every time she says some cases that
what happened in Beirut for her brand ya
know I I think when people will begin to
devolve on this issue to devolve on this
issue when gay divorce starts starts
popping up you'll see a lot of gay
people who will be like you know like I
don't know if it was right for me you
know gay marriage in theory is great but
yeah I want to go back to the single
what I do have a friend right now that's
a lesbian in the middle of divorce and I
feel like it's very that's very edgy
what do you think that is my teeny horse
first though you know they had a divorce
lesbian divorce they get married first
two they got a very first thing a
divorce first yeah there's some what u
haul joke were supposed yeah I walked up
to the edge of it and turn around go
he's not a good Ally he's not gonna make
that joke all right let's move on let's
talk about Lindsay Lohan you know she
had this show on own which is Oprah's
network that nobody knows what channel
it's on except for Oprah apparently and
the show got canceled he did one season
it just got cancelled it had poor
ratings surprise surprise and there's a
lot of drama around the show now I
actually hadn't watched the show until
we decided to do the second so I caught
up a little bit let's show you a little
clip of Lindsey show I may have
addictions to certain things in life but
I'm not essentially your typical addict
it's not going I'm not that kind of
person I know the difference between
right and wrong and stupid and it
idiotic and you know what's gonna bad
like I know that was raised well about
my variance but haven't seen it
but there's certain things that people
don't there's no one around people
sometimes I see that now we don't
usually do this kind of stuff on this
show but I thought this was particularly
interesting because it's related to
Oprah and how much truth there we get
mad at her and Lindsay's just such a
trainer so first just let's just talk
about the train wreck part of it um why
are we obsessed with train wrecks why
wyd no matter with justin bieber pees in
a slop bucket yells at Bill Clinton and
you know amanda Bynes bong out of a
window is my bond which is that was the
upsetting part it's like why were we
obsessed with these people well you see
celebrities climb very high and you
might even fall I mean it's part of the
kind of story we conditioned to expect
and so when someone is that famous in
that popular in that rich you kind of
expect this this downfall aspects to
happen that's like that way the story
ends yeah um I think Lindsay's been
around for so long we've seen ups and
downs um I personally watch the show
hoping it would be I mean I'm all those
people who actually want to succeed so
you thought that somehow she was gonna
be uh get her maiya culpa through this
well I don't know what I thought but I
kept watching so I mean it's it's tough
I mean she really is actually she's
trying she's also very diluted and so
you kind of see that in the show um that
what channel is it by the way I no idea
you don't even know and you've been why
I DVR day I don't know yeah I don't know
leave the DVR knows yeah what do you
think what's the train wreck explanation
cuz there's something deep in the human
psyche that loves this year well I think
part of it is actually in just a diction
to narrative and the fact that when
someone reaches the top that's if it was
a movie that be the end of the narrative
but in life it continues to go on so we
seek out the next part of the story we
want to see the next part of the story
and I think this is you know kind of a
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
it's like something that is watched will
be changed and when you start pointing a
camera and throwing paparazzi around
these people at all times like that will
drive someone crazy and I think we've
seen that with so many people now it's
I mean TMZ I have plays this tri-state
whenever somebody gets into serious
trouble at something really bad happens
teams he suddenly seems like really like
respectful wow that person yeah like
Siri really are praying for think you're
a big part of what happened here this is
someone who maybe didn't like shoot
someone but provided the gun their
pennies at all step over there easily
affected their views of all somebody
needs to put some of that powdered
alcohol in which is how we what the hell
his name from TMZ yeah 11 Harvey Levin
put it in his little any sucking on that
thing constantly uh this remind me a
little bit of that south park episode
with you know that humans we step human
sacrifice and now we're not sacrificing
these people to death but we were just
putting them up there for that so I
guess that sort of goes to what you're
saying about it there's like this deep
need in us is really dark as i get not
as dark as the show Lindsey yeah Brazil
darker than anything you said so the
part that made me really want to talk
about this though was the Oprah
connection because you know everything
Oprah's built herself on has been
actually what we think of our the
reverse of lindsay lohan and everyone
was like oh she's gonna give her a
chance and Oprah can fix Lindsay Lohan
cannot cuz / can do anything but even
Oprah failed did she fail amisha does
that I don't well makes me very sad the
whole show i'm still reeling yeah it's
been it's been a tough several weeks but
out I I think that I don't know it's
hard because with Oprah you you kind of
wonder did she come into this with good
intentions you know was she actually
trying to help someone that is that is
heard her thing so we believe that
everything but she also wants to make
money right you want somebody to watch
the channel at work so i think that it's
a mix look up for haitian lot Tyler
Perry programming is doing pretty well
do we have a laugh track and someone put
a laugh track never put on your show
you're you're you're laughing but it's
doing really well yeah um people love
people love Tyler Perry uh Lindsay not
so much but I think that it's a
combination of warming the ratings also
believing that I think she thought she
could craft a story where it is this
addict who has failed so many times
before but now she suddenly it's a come
to Jesus moment and Oprah is Jesus and
that's like that's what that's the show
but that was is it what happened cuz
Lindsey's not that predictable and you
can't kind of force an addict into that
narrative yeah so that's the part that I
think's interesting cuz this is if
that's the case let's give over all the
credit will she really did this he
helped Lindsay and you know all that
well then she sort of failed in her
mission right sure I I mean has she ever
failed before I'll write anything well
she did 12 ish with jam sorry sorry she
did was with James Frey and she let him
know that uh but I I don't know i think
the problem is also Lindsay's you know
who knows what her addiction and her
real situation is but there seems to be
a component of it where fame is enabling
the worst aspects of her addictions and
well I watched some of the show and it's
seemed to me that this was not a that
the way if you really wanted to help
Lindsay Lohan the way to help her was
not to put her exact line like to take
what's been driving her crazy and then
just blow it out times a million it
would be to remove her from the
spotlight and right so isn't that
something that sort of perverse I mean
Oprah must have thought of that like
you're gonna take like a Fame addicted
person right and she's probably did some
other things to which he sort of said
she was or was it wasn't really clear
there and then you're gonna give them
more of that like isn't that a little
justify devil's advocate there is an
asset of accountability to it and i
think that i watch Real Housewives to
Beverly Hills Kim Kimble bad in Madea
yeah I don't watch the tyler perry no
it's just it i know it exists um Kim
Richards recovering alcoholic said the
show basically saved her life because
she was being filmed all the time she
couldn't secretly drink she couldn't
avoid people call her an alcoholic on
camera yeah and made her get treatment
and that's the normal course of action
for an addict I'm just saying like there
is there is an aspect of accountability
when you're filming someone you know is
truly the greatest man alive the attics
yes I call him Bravo Andy because that's
what is twitter used to video whatever
shirt going um what do you guys how do
you personally deal with the train wreck
people cuz like amanda Bynes when she
was going off the rails and Bieber and
all that like I follow them on Twitter
just really purely for the jokes but
every now and again I do start like when
amanda Bynes was really going down the
tubes I started feeling bad and I was
like I'm
and a joke about her anymore cuz she
literally could just show up in a gutter
and then I'll I guess I'll feel bad but
how do you because you want to be part
of the zeitgeist right we're all in it
and I I think there's a difference
between someone like Justin Bieber who I
know it doesn't seem like there's an
addiction it doesn't seem like there's
it seems like he's kind of a smartass
kid and he does [ __ ] things on a
grand scale yeah I mean he is basically
Dennis the Menace with like a lot of
money and no accountability yeah where
is Lindsay Lohan and amanda Bynes there
seems to be some some actual medical
mental possibly issues at play and that
there's a difference between it feels
darker and meaner and it's the same way
when people joke about you know like
Miley Cyrus was in the hospital recently
for like a real like she had a bad
reaction to penicillin or something but
the the jokes immediately about you know
Oh what the STDs or oh she's pregnant
with so-and-so's and uh and it just
becomes you know what if something truly
terrible happens to this person so happy
how do you know threats i mean there's
you have to kind of fact a lot of things
in you know it's like how much of a dick
is that person so with justin bieber
like he's a he is a dick like that we
don't feel guilty for making fun of him
right um with someone who's clearly
struggling and you have to look at and
say like can I make a joke and live with
myself uh after doing so i think that uh
i hold back for a lot of people because
i don't be i could kind of cope with it
um and then everyone smaller someone
like bieber is a great example who just
I mean where's that there's no sympathy
for him like we're not worried about him
if he were clearly struggling maybe I
would step back but right now he's just
being Justin he's just a rich man that
spoiled rich kid is a this is a problem
but it's not like that something you can
you can treat medically so with that be
great yeah yeah but if a pill could fix
him give it to him but I don't think
that's gonna happen yeah alright well
said Bieber you're welcome to come on
the show anytime and defend yourself
we'd love to have you okay a lot of
people think Congress doesn't do much of
anything I am one of those people but
they're working hard for
you you know what they just did they
introduced a bill to cut down on
photoshopping of models in magazines
yeah this is your government working for
you it is called the truth in
advertising act and let's get an excerpt
from the bill an increasing amount of
academic evidence links exposure to such
altered images with emotional mental and
physical health issues including eating
disorders especially among children and
teenagers there's a particular concern
about the marketing of such images to
children and teenagers and of course you
know we see this all the time my
magazines and lately there's been a
trend of celebrities that release the
actual pictures of themselves I think
Lena Dunham is sort of started this
we've got some photoshopped images of
celebrities in case you're not sure of
what's going on on these magazines let's
take a look so this is Lindsay Lohan we
just talked about lindsay that's Lindsay
to the left and that is her airbrush
self to the right I mean without being
too glib about the segment we just did
before this she doesn't look back human
in either one of them but you can see
clearly like there's a lot of there's a
lot of alienus going on on that that
picture to the right and it's you know
clearly photoshopped and cleaned up and
all that her eyes look alien ish George
Clooney they took some wrinkles out and
his hair has a little more a little more
color guys feel free to chime where the
one after his way were like the befores
they like or looks great in after looks
awful is that funny they took the salt
and pepper out which everyone's like
that's the claim really add some change
was adam's apple' to make it more manly
yeah it's slightly darker right darkened
his eyebrows to its which is like one of
you was more like peter gallagher good
idea but it let's do it there's some
artists some we're going we better
darken his Adam's apple i mean they
literally said we need more contouring
right Adam's apple what's his name would
not be happy about that who got the
Adam's apple removed person bruce jenner
would not be happy about that one more
for you and we got the best possible
picture we could find of katy perry and
uh yeah i mean look at that to the left
you see a somewhat human horse with some
pores and that chin and then they they
what is this obsession with making ever
look like aliens it's very porcelain
doll it's like I want to see someone who
looks like they've never actually been
in the Sun ever
yeah I made in his sleep in moisturizer
I can't look at that anymore let's come
back over so yeah I think it's a great
bill actually like I think it's a really
good the problem is i might distrust of
Congress means that like what if it ever
gets passed it will be toothless and
nothing will happen and you know but
then again cigarette companies can't
advertise in a whole bunch of places
they used to be able to advertise yeah
although suddenly we have electronic
cigarette advertisements all over the
place that's your time yeah they're
gonna take that away to you I don't sure
yeah I think the building a far enough
really I think we should be
photoshopping people uglier I wanna say
I wanna see like put more flaws in two
people that make us feel better about
ourselves that would value yeah I would
be nice really just like ruin them yeah
I don't mean to be mean I'm just saying
like I want to see uh Katy Perry with
like a big gut and bad skin and like you
know just having a horrible hair day I
want to see that and not like a starts
without makeup I want to them to
actually create that image so what is
the for the people that read these
magazines and look at people that are
that already more beautiful than them or
richer than them and have all the things
that they don't have and then on top of
that they make them look even better
than they look normally what what is
going on like psychologically what do
you think is going awful I mean it's
creating a something to aspire to that
is fictional that literally is it does
not exist in the universe yeah and so
well right because they're starting to
look like you're starting to create a
situation where it's literally
unattainable like these goals are
unattainable and that causes perpetual
and completely complete failure it's
always going to be failure there's no
way to reach that zenith and it causes
awful mental health issues and eating
disorders and awful things I there's no
reason why we need Kate Upton to be my I
heard from a friend of a friend who was
working on that movie with Kate Upton
that they were he they were doing
digital effects to make her look like
slightly skinnier in the movie it's a
kate upton's gorgeous what are you
talking about right why do we need
skinny like nobody
like other thing about Kate Upton is how
tiny she is that it's insane well I
think there was something where promo
shot even of Hot in Cleveland where they
even tried to make Betty White look a
little slimmer and say but I really
liked sex her up because you really have
two sexy what trying to master a Betty
why you went away from that there is a
small group of people I'm sure that do
that um but are we all doing this in our
own life too because we all have that
Instagram thing and we can blur things
and we can make ourselves look Tanner
and all that so that is is that even
more perverse that regular people I
don't think segments really minor thing
everyone's look their best I don't think
that were actually unless you're like
actually photoshopping your instagrams
which is a thing people do do that um I
mean you know I had a friend who was
doing that secretly and I found out it
was one of the reasons I cut him out of
my life and I was like this is such a
fraud I was like this person is such a
fraud your photoshopping your own is I
can't do but since like online datings
existed we're always a coming our best
selves and like a perhaps a an altered
way we're table using angles to kind of
do what celebrity magazines yes I'm that
seems normal to me that's kind of just
human nature versus like actually
distorting someone's formats they look
like nothing like themselves and are
this like perfect for me just exist in
in the world by the way we have a
tremendous amount of Vaseline on the
lens here so that's a pretty damn well
rate right now um but to your to your
point when you started this whole thing
about Congress is there any chance
Congress like what does cognitive
anything to do with this like is this is
a type of thing Congress can't do
anything they have like a six percent
approval rating they literally can't
pass a law at this point nobody likes
them and this is what they're doing is
that sort of the state of America summed
up in a nutshell yes and no I actually
this is one of the issue one of the
times where I'm like well somebody's
trying to do something that has actual
impact like this I feel like a law like
this actually has much more impact on
regular america and could have much more
positive impact in regular America then
a lot of what kind of a lot of sense
that there are that's it I have no faith
in them to get anything done on this
issue yeah it's they're the worst
they're just for any final thoughts on
Congress uh yeah I mean I don't think
they have any control over magazine
today I mean I know how this work
something they can force it I mean most
likely they're just gonna set English
the guidelines like that won't that no
one would hear a nice change great so
good luck with your industry guidelines
people were all rooting for you okay uh
this was fascinating so according to the
LA times the number of Californians aged
50 to 64 who live in their parents homes
has surged in recent years people 50 to
64 moving back in every was just the
Millennials moving back in with mom and
dad know it's people in middle to upper
middle aged I got some more info for you
for seven years through 2012 the number
of Californians age 50 to 64 who live in
their parents homes well to sixty-seven
percent to about a hundred ninety four
thousand seems insane among 18 to 24
year olds 1.6 million Californians have
moved in with their parents though
that's a 33-percent jump from 2006 the
pace is still half that of the 50 to 64
age group uh there there's so much here
now none of us are in that age group yet
I am as will correct you looking great a
lot of a moisturizer but it is this
really an economic thing do you think
that that really is what's going on here
that these people just are falling on
hard economic times it seems weird for
that age group doesn't it yeah it does
but I feel like um well first I hope
this means that we can stop reading
millennial trend pieces if it's not the
Millennials like let's recent trend
pieces about 50 to 64 year old that was
one of the first things are going off
their parents yeah wasn't that nice a
jerk was it nice when you saw this
because it was like oh they're not just
died on how you know millennial yes
you're millennia so isn't it refreshing
you see some other age group be
besmirched I really hate boomers yeah
it's sad it's sad because like you know
our economic issues at play and um it's
more stigmatized move back home when
you're 50 than when you are 20 but um
yeah I also it is it is kind of like one
of those things where we look for her
trends like these lazy Millennials and I
feel like these issues kind of our the
economy at large not just like a group
of age of people being you know lazy not
working right so we've a bad economy all
together people just attack the
Millennials cuz they're the ones getting
in the workforce in a bad economy not
the ones were so obnoxious and it's like
we're easy targets
things with you people oh oh my goodness
um should we be judging these you know
look in Europe you know in Europe look
at Italy almost everyone lives with
their mother and yeah it's should we be
more like Italy I think I think we
should be more like Italy mother let me
stand food yeah at least if we know it's
I think it's sad more than anything and
I think it's a statement on the economy
in a huge way but I think it's also a
statement on the type of jobs that are
available and a lot of people in this
age group were trained for jobs that no
longer exist and aren't properly trained
for the jobs that are starting to exist
and the 50 is not you know that's
middle-aged and there's not a great way
to train a ton of middle-aged people to
learn the you know you want to you want
to do job training and you want to give
people a chance to get educated enough
to get back into the workforce but it
moves so quickly that by the time you
know somebody who's trained in computers
in the 90s is already if they haven't
been staying up with that is already
totally behind all right now yeah so
it's not just a bad economy but then
they're not trained properly for the for
the job that exists right now do we put
too much of a premium on getting out of
the house like even this reminds me of
like every episode of The Cosby Show
right cliff was always trying to get
those kill out of get out well any weed
we do though culturally you know you're
right though in Europe it's on the same
and many other countries is not the same
I mean the US has a weird thing about
kids going to college and never coming
back which is not realistic in this
economy so I think that um yets a weird
cultural thing I don't know if other
cultures are so into people who have
been out of the house for 30 years then
coming back right but um yeah I mean it
just seemed like a weird thing that
we've had a been conditioned to believe
that you have to kind of get out
immediately and never look back yeah
well it also makes sense though that
what started this terrible economy was
although it's starting to rebound but
what started the economy was the housing
crisis and so a lot of the people in the
50 to 64 Adrian probably owned houses
that were foreclosed upon and so they
were probably former homeowners who are
now renters who can't afford the rent
any would like it's the natural
conclusion
of people who were foreclosed on eight
years ago yeah I mean there's definitely
a litany of reasons that's going is
there something nice actually about
people this age moving back in you know
you have elderly parents are probably in
their 80s or 90s at this point and you
know people do it's usually thought of
the other way that the elderly parent
moves in with the child or they kick
them off to to Shady Pines so does gonna
get one golden girls represent
appreciate uh so but is there something
nice about this that we should actually
respect more you know like in Japan
where they really have a respect for the
elderly that we sort of don't have here
was a bum me out about the LA Times
piece um the woman in the piece says
that it was because of her twins that
she was back in if they had not been
around she would've lived in a car so I
was like as her mom reading this because
of my mom read that I'd rather live in
my car than with my mom I think she'd be
a little upset yeah well we'll link to
the article in the description by the
way so you can find out about a bit more
about her yeah it's just depressing it's
so sad and it is nice to be with family
and to be but nobody wants to come back
hat in hand and the also nobody wants to
be written up in the LA Times about how
they came back at it look you're already
embarrassing enough but to go to be like
yeah so then my life really fell apart
and now I have to live with my parents
my kids like that sucks like not
everybody read about yeah well from
getting older in a bad economy to robots
taking your jobs yeah that's right you
know last week we did the story on this
study about how in 2060 basically
because of an aging population that's
going to stay alive and people having
less kids that our whole economic system
can be flipped upside down we're going
to a class war between old people and
young people read Albert Brooks 2030 if
you haven't now futurologists are saying
they well they're basically making bold
predictions about what's going to happen
in 20-40 to the workforce this is from
xpat jobs com let's take a look so here
are some of the things that they predict
will be happening by 2040 this is not
that long from now we may be requesting
Bionic implants for our hands that will
make us able to perform tasks as fast as
any machine plastic surgeons will be
able to offer additional brain
processing power I could use that the
current 37.4 hour work week will
increase
a third 250 and a half hours and we will
have less sex in a lifetime as a result
of reduced human interaction I think
some of these things are already
happening above so let's look at what
the worker will look like in 20 40
workers will have red eyes from working
all hours also maybe from being the
Terminator weaker eyes from close-up
wearable devices much like Google glass
that we've been talking a lot about a
smaller penis as a result of fewer
sexual partners over a lifetime as human
interaction reduces I didn't know that
your penis grows in relation to how much
sex you're having a bigger brain with
software and memory updates we're just
going to put a little will sim card in
our ear I guess implanted ear where to
eliminate cumbersome bluetooth headsets
and smart phones and smart fingers with
chips that aid work ok so I painted the
future for your 2040 you're not buying
it this is such nonsense we're gonna
look back at this segment exactly Pat's
got jobs com I'm calling shenanigans
yeah we're gonna look back at this
segment the same way we look back at
Popular Mechanics issues from the 40s
you know Oh cities will fly high above
us like no it's this that won't happen
the idea that technology is going to
reduce sexual interaction is crazy if
anything we've seen the exact opposite
to be true Google glass is not gaining a
foothold if anything people are
rejecting the weirdness of it I think
being conditioned by years and years and
years of dystopian future movies and
novels have made us very suspicious of
the computers that commenters tell me
every week i watch way too many sci-fi
yeah we're not that we're not going to
be like oh we can have a droid that can
do our jobs yeah I'd like to hire that
droid maybe I shouldn't smoke we watch
total recall every night before I go to
know that you should do because that's
just a good life choice but uh this is
just a I mean it's fun to think about
but it's also crazy not side okay I'm
gonna fight you back a little bit on
that but I let you go first I grief Jack
although I do want to be I do want to be
that person who's like TVs a fabric I
want to look back in the other way
Billy's these guys and believe us we
were totally right you want to be back
at I want to be the guy who's wrong but
uh no I think it's all it's it's
complete [ __ ]
I do think the sex parts actually true I
disagree Jack on that I think that uh we
have reduced interaction and that the
movie her was like very true to life or
will be bred some time will we will be
able to kind of find connectivity in and
sort of a sexual release outside of
human partners right well already I mean
I don't know you know this but there's
porn on the internet heard about that
yeah i haven't seen any but I've heard
that that's the thing yeah I would argue
that the last 20 years have led to a
much more promiscuous like I feel like
society's much more promiscuous now than
it was in the 1950s right and a big part
of that is because we're watching a lot
of porn and where people are getting
married much later in life you know it's
it's the number of 20-somethings I know
myself included who are like oh I'm not
even gonna think about getting married
till I'm 30 you like that would never
that would've been crazy talk in
nineteen nineteen fifty and you know the
rise of tinder and grinder and it's
these things are made so people can like
get their rocks off together like nobody
right you know right there's plenty of
room to do it alone but yes you can do
it i don't think anybody's been like you
know porns been so great I'm just done
with sex like I don't I think of
anything it has the opposite effect
where I don't know yeah if you could
have a sex robot over having to deal
with a human being I feel like you might
go over the sex we've talked a lot about
the sex robots they're coming to no pun
intended I they're coming I think I
think sex reversal industry I think you
nailed it right there about people Don
Draper oh so worried about how to pitch
the sexual exactly so okay so I to me it
seems like a lot of this stuff is
actually possible because it's only 20
something years in the future and if you
think about what what we were like 20
years ago we didn't know about phones
air pocket we were connected to the
internet all time we wouldn't even be
able to believe all the stuff we could
do now so that's why I look at this list
and yet maybe our eyes won't be turning
red but like the rest of it seems kinda
yeah like we can't nobody can predict
what point you know there's that famous
quote from the Microsoft guy like 1981
is like know where the future will ever
anyone ever need more than four
megabytes of data you know like I feel
like that's why I kinda buy into this
tough am i crazy futurist you're insane
i think that no III get that I think
that but at the same time with the
things that have happened
we victim accent like exactly know but
the things that happen I think are also
kind of in line with what we expected to
some degree like video calls I mean what
what is actually happening that's that
outside of what we could've imagined
right what we thought the video calls to
be on this big machine and it ended up
in our in our hands right so I mean yeah
I these things happen but happen in such
extreme ways only by 2040 were to see a
drastically different I mean there might
be a nuclear war that weapons all out
before that but if if we survive story
this week we're gonna if we survive I
don't need to be that drastically
different um these happen kind of
gradually as they're happening is it
feels that way so I don't think it's
gonna be somewhere to wake up suddenly
with robots working all our jobs yeah I
also think technology has made us more
connected than maybe I'm buying what
Mark Zuckerberg is selling but i do
think technology's made us more
connected than we've ever been I have
met I met both of you on the internet
that guy through Twitter and through had
nothing to do with sex ya know yeah well
first but no I mean I like this is a
human interaction that's occurring that
wouldn't have occurred this is being
broadcast you know like it's that we're
becoming more I don't think human
interaction is is lessening and I don't
think that anybody is thinking that oh
if only I could just talk to smarter
child or one of those other like clever
bot or one of those instead of being on
Twitter like interacting with actual
people I think we may have less
face-to-face contact at some point but I
think there will always be a need for
face-to-face contact and I think even
video calls we're about face to face
contact like it's and even that's not
really take i mean skype is a big part
of meetings and big but the idea of like
talking to your friend in the same city
on a video call I still feel like is
like not the most common thing despite
what you know some TV shows because it's
a clever it's an easy way to get people
in the same room like I don't think
that's like really taken off in a huge
way I think in 20 in 20-40 things are
gonna look a lot like they will now only
with maybe like smaller phones and
hopefully their cars shortly giant retro
phone all the Zack Morris yeah
yeah yeah all right well Jack you've
given us a very pleasant ending here i
think uh Jack Moore Lewis Heitzman their
twitters are right down below and you
guys need to like and do the share and
what are some other buzzword buttons
give me something comment comment engage
engage highly in what we're doing here
because that's what you do right now and
then one day maybe we'll meet in person
and this will all be beautiful alright
thanks for watching we'll see you